and finally new rule and this one goes
out to Republicans guys there's no shame
in punting you can't score every time
you get the ball sometimes you wind up
with really horrible field position and
then what do you do punt funds you're
going to lose this election
you're gonna lose with either Trump or
Cruz so just punt helped put Hillary
Clinton in the oval office and you'll
have her right where you want her I know
it sounds crazy but the only way you can
win this November is by losing now
before you jump all over this let's not
pretend that Republicans aren't already
flirting with this idea Christy Todd
Whitman says she'll vote for Hillary
over Trump Bill Kristol of The Weekly
Standard sat right here and said he
won't vote for the Republican candidate
if it's Donald Trump the National Review
did an entire issue called against Trump
the National Review coming out against
the Republican frontrunner
it's like High Times coming out against
me
so we all know you're not happy with
your choices right now but it's getting
near closing time and you're gonna have
to go home with one of them either
either Ted Cruz a man with all the
appeal of Jared from Subway - the
inspiring weight loss or Donald Trump
these zombie candidate but there is a
third choice punt punt give the ball to
your defense you've got a great defense
and by that I mean you're great at being
obstructionist [ __ ] when you're out
of office
our our current teabagger Congress
proves that you can't govern any more
you don't even want to governing means
doing things in government which you
hate I know you say you want your
country back but really I think you're
like the video gamer who finally lands a
date with a real woman you'd have no
idea what to do with does this Trump
supporter for example really want to fix
what's wrong with America no the only
thing that would make him happy is going
back in time to when his penis worked
and there and there were in Spanish
Stations of the rikiya so let Hillary
have the next four years the Republican
Party's gonna need that time anyway
to rebuild and I'm talking about a
top-to-bottom renovation my god the GOP
right now it's like one of those houses
were an old lady lived with a hundred
cats who peed everywhere yes
yes that is your party today
a filthy P stained house full of dead
cats do you really want to live there
for the next four years do you really
want to spend four years defending every
single thing that President Trump tweets
in the middle of the night defending
every stupid thing that he does when he
invades Poland or puts Hulk Hogan on the
nickel or or retweets our nuclear cold
it's gonna be new explaining it to Wolf
Blitzer but just think of the fun things
you could be doing a year from now with
Hillary Clinton in office like
forwarding pictures of her Photoshop to
look like this guys
guys Obama is almost gone
soon he'll be back with his socialist
tribe in Kenya and then who are you
gonna hate every day I'm not sure I'm
ready for Hillary but you you've been
getting ready for 25 years
whitewater filegate travelgate who gives
a [ __ ] game who's gonna save democracy
from the email she wrote in 2009 how are
we gonna find the island where bill
keeps all his Russian sex slaves you put
so much work into the email thing and
ginning up in Ghazi you're rock hard and
ready to shoot but remember you can't
impeach her if you don't elect her